[Musique]
découvrir l'hémicycle du département
mieux comprendre les mission de la
collectivité et surtout s'asseoir dans
le sacre au sein des sains à savoir les
fauteuils des conseillers départementaux
c'est l'expérience vécue par tous les
délégués de classe du collège poul
Herman de
Saint-Pierre un département c'est une
collectivité territoriale et pour vous
c'est quoi une collectivité territoriale
qui sont les élus qui sient au
ou encore comment s'installe la
commission permanente ou tout simplement
qui est votre conseiller départemental
autant de questions pour mieux
appréhender la vie citoyenne en classe
de 5e ils ont à apprendre sur
l'instructioninstruction civique donc
c'est vrai que les collèg nous sollicite
pour faire connaître les mission du
département et je pense que c'est très
intéressant parce que les collégiens qui
arrivent en général n'ont pas toujours
les informations et quand ils sortent de
cette visite citoyenne on ont beaucoup
appris et ça leur permet de prendre
conscience des missions du département
que la collectivité fait quand même
beaucoup de choses pour la population
dans différents domaines une visite qui
s'inscrit dans le cursus scolaire
puisque l'éducation civique est une
matière à part entière pour tous ces
collégiens une matière importante qui
leur permet de mieux comprendre la vie
politique
locale un jeune ne va pas se dire de
façon spontanée en fait comment ça
fonctionne la vie politique de ma ville
donc c'est vrai que c'est un premier
déclic où ils sont fiers puisque du coup
ils ont quelques connaissances et ils
peuvent échanger le soir avec leurs
parents et du coup
peut-être c'est généralement le début
d'une démarche où ils vont peut-être
plus regarder les actualités ça va plus
leur parler parce qu's sauront ils
auront visité cet endroit et je pense
que c'est le déclic de pas mal de choses
et des connaissances ils en ont rangé à
l'image de Livine qui ne s'intéresse pas
mais alors pas du tout à la
politique politique c'est pas TR mon
truc non plus c'est la première fois que
je viens je trouve que c'est une
présentation plutôt impressionnant oui
j'ai appris des choses mais il y a des
choses aussi que je savais déjà ben je
retiens toutes les actions que le
Conseil départemental mène pour
améliorer la vie des habitants
réunionnés et tous les projets qui sont
menés pour la vie quotidienne pour
améliorer la vie quotidienne des
réonnais voir comment la vie se
développe dans le futur et une visite
qui s'est terminé par une rencontre fort
suite avec la présidente comme on
s'occupe des collèges par exemple dans
cette classe si on vous demande on fait
un rêve le Père Noël passe qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est-ce que vous avez envie qu'on
vous apporte qu'est-ce que vous aimez le
plus vous aimez visiter vous aimez
voyager vous aimez vous voulez quoi
voyager voy et c'est devant le palais de
la source où la présidente préside au
destinés de notre département que la
photo souvenir a été prise pour le plus
grand bonheur des
collégiens
[Musique]